(upbeat sync music)
- [Narrator] This, my
friends, is the story
of the real New Yorker's sandwich
and the people who keep the legacy alive.
- I've been eating here for 20 years.
(upbeat jazz music)
- [Narrator] On 110th and 1st Avenue,
inside the bodega best known
as Hajji's, we meet Salah.
- Yo, boss, let me get two chopped cheese
with everything on it.
- Lettuce, tomato, pickle, ketchup.
- Put bacon on it, too,
salt, pepper, and vinegar.
(upbeat jazz music)
- [Narrator] Hajji's is
located in a part of New York
that's made up of various kinds
of people with a variety of incomes,
so keeping chopped cheese at a price point
everyone can afford has
been a top priority.
In fact, the chopped cheese has only
gone up a dollar in the last decade.
- [Narrator] That's why the chopped cheese
has spread beyond Harlem and
into bodegas far and wide,
attracting loyal New Yorkers
everywhere it appears.
But in the end, it all comes
back to Hajji's and Salah.
(mellow rock music)
(contemplative synth music)